we hope you're ready folks because today
we're discussing the most dangerous scp
of all time we know you've probably
heard this before but seriously this one
is the absolute top of the pyramid of
fear or the fear amid if you will this
scp makes 682 weep and terror for its
life it makes the old man
scp-106 consider turning his life around
and taking up a career in humanitarian
work it even makes the dreaded scarlet
king himself the lord of chaos the
ultimate despair quake in his spiky red
boots it's just that utterly terrifying
just kidding it's lego but we had you
going there for a second didn't we
though it may not actually be the
scariest anomaly of all time
scp-387 isn't your granddad's lego set
either unless your granddad goes by
agent hardy and works for the scp
foundation hardy is one of the hundreds
of thousands of foundation field agents
planted all over the globe in everything
from law enforcement to surveillance
ever watchful for the kinds of anomalies
the scp foundation makes it their
mission to secure contain and protect
but when he discovered
scp-387 he wasn't even technically on
duty he was taking a long train journey
home from his parents house while his
car was in the shop and as anyone who's
ever taken a long train journey knows
without proper stimulation boredom will
crop up in no time he'd been reading a
pretty interesting book on his e-reader
when tragedy first struck and it ran out
of battery hardy had forgotten to bring
his charging cable so he was potentially
looking at another three hours of
mind-numbing monotony that's when he
noticed the red plastic tub that had
been apparently abandoned in the seat
across from him he realized in that
moment that had been there the whole
time unsupervised given that he was a
foundation field agent and was as such
extremely curious he grabbed the tub and
took a look inside hoping to find
something that'll quell his growing
boredom lucky for him the box was full
of lego bricks everyone's favorite brand
of toy construction block the tub was
brimming with a vast collection of
pieces some of which like wheels and
prisms agent hardy had never seen before
despite spending his childhood
obsessively making lego constructions
but hardy wasn't one to criticize a gift
from the universe this tub of lego
pieces would be the perfect way to keep
himself entertained for the rest of his
long journey he spent the next hour or
so meticulously recreating site 19 in
lego form on the table in front of him
when the building was done he decided to
have some fun and populate the site with
a collection of lego men standing in for
scp foundation scientists containment
specialists and guards after finding a
torso with a lab coat in the box agent
hardy decided to make a tiny dr bright
to start with however as soon as he made
the tiny lego scientist and set it down
on his new site 19 playset he realized
that everything was not as innocently
typical as it seemed the little man
instantly began to walk immediately
picking up a tiny lego clipboard and
heading towards the euclid containment
wing agent hardy had discovered a brand
new anomaly on his day off while playing
with toys on a boring train ride
philosopher l p jacks was certainly
right when he said a master in the art
of living draws no sharp distinction
between his work and his play naturally
agent hardy immediately took the little
lego man apart along with his site 19
simulacrum and alerted his superiors at
the scp foundation his co-workers met
him at the next train stop platform not
long after the box of seemingly living
lego pieces redesignated
scp-387 was in the hands of foundation
researcher dr arch his first priority
was finding out what exactly they were
all dealing with here whether there was
more of it out there and whether it was
dangerous attempts to investigate the
origins of scp-387 were mostly fruitless
undercover foundation agents
investigated every lego-producing
location they could find but found no
evidence of anything similar to 387
being produced and of course as with
anything that seemed to be an anomalous
toy all possible links to dr
wondertainment were also explored but
again nothing came up this was probably
for the best if 387 was a dr
wondertainment product it probably would
have built itself into an actual sized
dinosaur and started eating people
already all further investigations into
387's origins were subsequently dropped
with background research turning out to
be a dead end dr arch decided to get
down to business doing the fun part
actual experimentation after gathering
all the proper permissions from his
superiors the testing commenced in
experiment 387-8
dr arch recruited a number of
lego-loving d-classes after all even
convicted robbers arsonists and
murderers loved lego and made them
construct a little lego community inside
a testing chamber this consisted of a
small main street with a number of lego
stores a residential area and a bar as
soon as the d-classes constructed a
variety of little lego men and released
them into the community they instantly
came to life and began performing their
roles perfectly some took up jobs in the
various stores cafes and boutiques
others acted as patrons for the
different businesses the lego men were
even noted as forming rudimentary family
units one man did fall into the river in
this lego city but otherwise things were
going smoothly encouraged by these
developments dr arch was ready to begin
the true experiment introducing a
complex new variable into the
environment of the lego men and seeing
exactly how they reacted he had another
d-class build a commercial airliner out
of normal non-anomalous lego bricks and
place it just to the side of the lego
community over the following three-hour
period dr arch observed the lego man
engaging in some truly remarkable
behavior upon noticing the plane the
lego man began to form a plan they first
procured the necessary equipment from
the scp-387 tub and headed over to the
plane for a hard day's work in lego man
time at least with remarkable efficiency
the citizens of the lego community began
forming a fully functional airport
around the plain multiple runways an air
traffic control tower and even a mall
and food court within the airport itself
tiny lego attendants tried to sell
perfume to uninterested lego commuters
and lego tsa agents frisked
uncomfortable would-be lego passengers
its accuracy to the real-life airport
experience was truly brilliant but they
didn't stop there a tiny lego fuel truck
sped over to the plane and acted out the
process of refueling it a lego pilot and
his lego co-pilot climbed into the plane
and it took off literally flying around
the room without any kind of logical
propulsion system dr arch was amazed and
even then they didn't stop they
continued to build more planes of
various makes and models resulting in a
sprawling airport that if you squinted
would look just like the real thing from
this dr arch concluded that the 387 lego
man had the ability to convert
non-anomalous lego pieces into anomalous
ones he proceeded to the next experiment
for experiment 387-b dr arch decided to
switch up the d-classes and instead
brought in some of lego's more
traditional target audience a group of
10 year old children they began building
some basic constructions out of the
pieces your typical buildings people and
cars but when they realized that their
creations were actually alive their tune
immediately changed the kids spoken
hushed excited tones about a new plan
and then began putting it into practice
they built functional transformers and
just to be clear it wasn't electrical
transformers they crafted we're talking
transformers as an actual optimus prime
and megatron an m1 abrams tank and a
number of different lego weapons of mass
destruction dr arch was mortified
realizing that he'd apparently gathered
up a team of budding childhood super
villains and had them removed from the
test chamber for amnestic treatment
immediately however the second the test
chamber was vacated the kids creations
came to life and entered a state of
all-out war it was an intense battle
lasting about an hour and left no lego
survivors just a huge mess around the
room while this test was largely an
embarrassment for all involved it did
lead to some interesting new data not
only was this anomaly safe in the sense
that it didn't pose a containment breach
it was also safe in the more colloquial
sense there was no way these lego bricks
could hurt you unless you decided to eat
them and choked don't do that by the way
we see you don't scp-387 is unable to
perform dangerous actions if humans of
any age are present in the vicinity and
this arrangement goes both ways too the
lego creations will be alive and to some
extent sentient if played with
peacefully however if the human playing
with them becomes hostile then they will
immediately become inanimate so play
nice folks next came experiment 387-c
and experiment
387-c2 where dr arch turned his
attention to the tub itself since
scp-387 came into the foundation's
possession the quantity of 387 blocks
had increased how is this possible
you're probably wondering dr arch and
his team discovered an interesting
phenomena when some of the scp-387 is
placed back in the red tub but the red
tub isn't filled then 387 will
self-duplicate to fill out the tub much
like the way a gas will disperse to fill
out any containment unit it finds itself
inside however dr arch also discovered
some interesting limitations there
seemed to be no inherent anomalous
qualities to the red tub itself during
one of the experimentations dr arch
half-filled the red tub with
non-anomalous lego pieces and found that
nothing changed similarly he performed
another experiment where he placed a
single scp-387 brick into the box and
found there was no difference when he
came back dr arch and his associates
came to the conclusion that the
anomalous properties are confined solely
to the bricks themselves but they have a
kind of symbiotic relationship with the
red tub as they don't replicate in any
other containment units in order to
activate replication the 387 must cover
the entire bottom layer of the tub next
came experiment
387-d where dr arch hoped to test the
specific activation mechanisms of
scp-387
the lego creations animated whenever
they were assembled by a child or an
adult so it wasn't an age-regulated
anomaly the next experiment involved
using a remotely controlled robotic arm
to create a lego construction to see if
the mere act of construction itself was
enough to instigate 387's primary
anomalous effect however this didn't
turn out to be the case the robotic arm
assembled lego construction never came
alive dr arch's next hypothesis was that
perhaps flesh was needed to activate
scp-387 but how could he test using
flesh without just having a normal human
assemble the lego pieces thankfully the
answer came to dr arch by total accident
a few cells over an anomaly trying to
breach containment had just killed a
foundation agent trying to stand in its
way while the d-classes cleaned up the
mess dr arch dragged the body over to
where the 387 tests were being conducted
and meticulously puppeteered its arms
and hands to put together more 387 lego
constructions but once again it didn't
come to life interesting next hypothesis
maybe it needs warmth to activate in a
move that proved unpopular with
co-workers just trying to eat their
pre-packaged sandwiches in the site 19
break room dr arch dragged the dead
foundation agent's body over towards the
room's radiator and leaned its arms and
hands over the top of it for 20 minutes
before giving his newly discovered
puppeteering skills another go but once
again nothing happened dr arch concluded
that perhaps human psychic energy or
maybe an active pulse was what caused
387 to activate if you're waiting for
the horrifying twist well aside from the
puppeteering of a dead coworker's limbs
we're pleased to tell you that there
just isn't one this time
scp-387 serves no containment breach
risk and no risk of harm to foundation
personnel in fact playing with the
living lego has led to an 87 percent
increase in morale for foundation staff
so as long as you fill in the proper
forms and tidy up afterwards you're
actually allowed to play with the
scp-387 anytime you want after all
working for the scp foundation is a
stressful job and really we're all
children at heart oh and there was one
more experiment experiment 387-e where
lego community was built using scp-387
and then a pile of mega bloks lego's
most common imitator was introduced into
the mix the lego men of the community
really weren't pleased by this while the
actual details of what happened have
thankfully been expunged the one clue to
what may have happened came from a note
left by dr arch that's right the
puppeteer guy his notes on that
experiment were four simple words oh no
not again now go check out
scp-1007 mr life and mr death and
scp-5094 miss j's wizkid schoolhouse for
more fascinating safe class scps